es muy común que escuchemos las palabras
de precisión y amortización y mi
objetivo en este vídeo es comprender a
qué se refieren y cuál es la ligera
diferencia entre ambas en un ejemplo
anterior vimos lo que es depreciación
vimos un ejemplo en el que imaginamos
que en el periodo cero compramos un
camión por 60 mil dólares y en lugar de
gastarlo en el periodo cero un gasto de
60 mil dólares directamente acá lo
capitalizamos tenemos un bien de 60 mil
dólares así que al final del periodo
cero o al inicio del primer período
lo que hacemos es separar este gasto
entre el período de tiempo que vamos a
hacer uso de este camión así que en el
período 1 de apreciamos el camión en 20
mil dólares asumiendo que tenemos una
vida útil de tres años de este camión
vamos a hacer una depreciación de línea
directa tomamos el costo del camión y lo
dividimos entre la vida útil de este y
así lo vamos apreciando ustedes podrían
imaginarse que se desprecia más rápido
durante el primer año parece la forma
más sencilla de ser después de que lo le
apreciamos 20 mil dólares o de que lo
usamos por 20 mil dólares
estamos en este año es literalmente un
gasto al final del primer periodo ahora
en nuestro libro de bienes va a valer 40
mil dólares durante el segundo periodo
lo deprecia nosotros 20 mil dólares va a
ser un gasto durante el periodo 2 y
ahora nuestro libro de bienes va a valer
20 mil dólares al final del segundo
periodo en el tercer periodo gastamos o
despreciamos otros 20 mil dólares y al
menos para este camión asumiendo que no
hemos comprado otro lo hemos gastado
todo nos queda un valor de 0 ya que
debido a lo que asumimos ya no es útil
esto es la depreciación
ahora imaginen que para seguir con
nuestro negocio de camiones tenemos que
pagar un tipo de licencia un pago por
licencia pago por licencia y vamos a
imaginar que este pago de licencia
cuesta cuatro mil dólares y tiene una
duración de cuatro años y nuevamente
podemos escribir aquí un gasto de cuatro
mil dólares pero esto no es muy acertado
no estamos usando toda esta licencia en
este periodo está licencia va a ser útil
durante cuatro periodos así que de nuevo
tenemos aquí el bien la licencia pagada
y luego amortizamos este pago en los
periodos de su vida útil de igual manera
que lo hicimos con el camión tomamos ese
valor original y lo dividimos entre los
periodos en los que nos va a ser útil
4000 entre 4 años pues van a hacer mil
dólares por año en el primer año va a
ser 1 en mis libros base es de 10 mil
dólares en el segundo año se amortiza
por otros 1000 dólares en los libros nos
quedan dos mil dólares en el tercer
periodo otros mil dólares al final de
ese periodo nos quedan mil dólares en el
libro finalmente en el cuarto período
en otros 1000 dólares y en mis libros
queda con un valor de 0 que
probablemente necesite comprar otra
licencia matemáticamente son la misma
cosa incluso filosóficamente son lo
mismo la idea de que en lugar de hacer
los gastos en un solo momento si vemos
que tienen una vida útil vamos a
dispersar o a repartir estos gastos
durante toda esa vida útil la diferencia
entre estos dos y es posible que ustedes
ya se hayan dado cuenta de esto es que
depreciación se aplica cuando tienen
bienes tangibles un edificio un camión
algo que pueden tocar a esto se le
aplica el término depreciación si
tenemos un bien intangible o un bien
financiero o algo menos tangible
entonces él aplica el término de
amortizar la diferencia en los términos
depende de qué tan tangible es el bien
si tenemos algún pago de licencia o
incluso una propiedad intelectual se
amortiza el costo si tenemos un camión o
un edificio entonces se deprecia